in videos gtx 980 and gtx 970 the
latter's memory issues notwithstanding
are the current kings of power efficient
GPU performance but for the vast
majority of people such pixel pushing
power is unnecessary enter the gtx 960
in videos entry into the hotly contested
bid range market where 1080p and a sub
$200 price tag rule like his bigger
brothers the gtx 960 is based on the
power sipping Maxwell architecture this
time on the smaller GM 206 chip this
runs at a base clock of 1126 megahertz
with a boost clock of 1178 megahertz
there are eight SSM cuticle clusters for
a total of 1024 processors and just 32
ROPS while the memory interface is
bumped down from 256 to 128 bit with 2
gigabytes onboard the reduced memory
bandwidth will have an effect on
performance but it's offset by the use
of some superfast gddr5 memory and some
nifty memory compression technology for
a total bandwidth of 112 gigabytes a
second for those building smaller
systems the real draw here is the gtx
960 s excellent power efficiency with a
TDP of just 120 watts it's entirely
possible to build a full core i7 system
overclock it and still have a computer
that pulls under a meager 250 Watts
under load that's seriously impressive
power efficiency it also results in a
GPU that runs very cool and thus very
quiet MS eyes implementation of the gtx
960 makes use of his twin throws a
cooling system complete with some
serious looking heat pipes and hefty tox
fans note that unlike a blower design
MSI's implementation vents hot air into
the case so good air flow is a must
those working with particularly small
and
cramps Assis all want a blower style
card not to mention something a little
smaller thanks to the msi is twenty six
point five centimeter length the benefit
to all that cooling goodness provided
you have good airflow it's a card that
doesn't even have to spin up its fans at
idle or under light loads and even when
it's stressed it's extremely quiet
that's another power efficiency victory
for Maxwell and a win for MSI's cooler
connectivity wise there's just a single
eight pin power connector to hook up
along with one dual link DVI output one
HDMI and three full-sized display ports
all gtx 960 support the upcoming direct
x12 along with in videos full suite of
game works which you can learn about in
our gtx 980 review right here so the gtx
960 s got the features but how does it
perform hooked up to our core i7 3770k
system with sixteen gigabytes of ddr3
ram the card breezed through most all
are 1080p benchmarks running our test
suite of games at above sixty frames per
second with all the settings cranked
naturally the only game not to do so was
perennial system breaker Crysis 3 which
managed a playable but not entirely
smooth 40 frames per second average as
for higher resolutions the gtx 960 isn't
the best choice particularly as it only
has 2 gigabytes of memory but there are
playable frame rates that hover above 30
frames per second to be had at 1440p if
your entire gaming life revolves around
stuff like dota League of Legends or
counter-strike then naturally 1440p are
well above 60 frames per second is no
problem for this card performance is
good then but not earth-shattering in
the same way as the GTX 970
that said it is noticeably faster than
the outgoing GTX 760 and uses less power
and if you're running an older 660 or
560 it's certainly worth the upgrade
AMD's offerings at the same price are
very competitive though that's
especially true of the r9 280 which
retails for the same $200 that actually
features a 384 bit memory interface and
three gigabytes of memory yes it's based
on an old architecture but it stands
toe-to-toe with the gtx 960 on
performance and the extra memory is
great for those games with large
textures or if you're into modern games
like Skyrim so the gtx 960 might not be
the revolution in value that the GTX 970
was and the two gigabytes of memory is
stingy by today's standards but there's
still no touching in video when it comes
to power efficiency resulting in the
coolest quietest cards around if you're
after a capable 1080p GPU it's a good
choice for the cache
but with GPU memory requirements on the
rise I'm keen to see what AMD can come
up with later this year